en el último vídeo te mostré cómo se ve
una neurona y hablamos de las diferentes
partes de una neurona y tenía una idea
general de lo que hace una neurona es
estimulada en las dendritas y hablaremos
en vídeos futuros de qué significa esta
estimulación exactamente y ese impulso
esa información
esa señal se suma si hay múltiples
puntos de estimulación en varias
benditas se suma y si llega al valor del
umbral generará este potencial de acción
o señal que viaja a través de la acción
y quizás estimule otras neuronas son
músculos porque estos botones terminales
de la acción podrían estar conectados a
dendritas de otras neuronas las células
musculares entre otras cosas
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
sentar las bases que expliquen
exactamente lo que es esta señal o cómo
una neurona de hecho transmite la
información a través de la acción cómo
va de la bendita por todo el camino
hasta el axón antes de que incluso hable
de eso necesitamos sentar las reglas
básicas o un entendimiento base del
voltaje a través de la membrana de una
neurona y de hecho todas las células
tienen algo de diferencia de potencial
pero es especialmente relevante cuando
hablamos de una neurona y su habilidad
para mandar señales hagamos un
acercamiento a una neurona déjame solo
hacer un acercamiento en esta parte
puedo hacer un acercamiento en cualquier
punto de esta célula que no esté
cubierto por una vaina de mielina haré
un acercamiento en la membrana déjame ir
aquí abajo digamos que esta es la
membrana de la neurona justo así esta es
la membrana de la neurona
este es el exterior es el ex-
prior de la neurona y luego este es el
interior él
peor
de la neurona ahora tienes iones de
sodio y potasio flotando alrededor
dibujaré al sodio de esta manera el
sodio será un círculo
este es el sodio son guiones cargados
positivamente y tienen una carga de más
1 y luego el potasio lo dibujaré con
pequeños triángulos digamos que ese es
el potasio el símbolo para el potasio es
acá también está cargado positivamente
digamos que los tienes por ahí y digamos
que ambos empiezan adentro y afuera de
la célula déjame dibujar algo de potasio
lo dibujaré con un triángulo
debe tener carga positiva hay algo de
potasio dentro de la célula y hay algo
de potasio afuera con una carga positiva
y luego hay algo de sodio dentro de la
célula
todos tienen carga positiva algo de
sodio adentro y algo de sodio afuera
ahora resulta que las células tienen una
mayor cantidad de cargas positivas
afuera de sus membranas que adentro de
sus membranas hay de hecho una
diferencia de potencial si la membrana
no estuviera ahí las cargas negativas
querrían escapar o las cargas positivas
querrían entrar déjame escribir eso el
lado exterior acaba siendo más positivo
hablaremos de la razón más
o
co
y acá podemos decir menos positivo menos
o sí
bo
este es un gradiente de potencial
eléctrico si esto es menos positivo que
eso sí tengo una carga positiva aquí
querrá ir al lado menos positivo querrá
alejarse de las otras cargas positivas y
repelida por las otras cargas positivas
de una manera similar si tengo una carga
negativa aquí esta querrá ir al otro
lado o imagino que una carga positiva
estaría más feliz aquí que acá pero la
pregunta es cómo sucede eso porque con
sus propios medios las cargas se
dispersarían así que no tendrías este
gradiente de potencial de alguna manera
tenemos que poner energía en el sistema
para poder producir este estado donde
tenemos más cargas positivas en el
exterior que en el interior y eso se
hace con las bombas de sodio potasio
las dibujar es de esta manera no es
exactamente como se ve la proteína pero
te dará una idea de cómo bombea a los
iones hacia afuera dibujaré este lado de
la proteína quizás se vea de esta manera
y verás porque la dibujo de esta manera
este es un lado de la proteína o enzima
y el otro lado lo dibujaré de esta
manera
se ve algo así
y por supuesto que la proteína real no
se ve de esta manera ya he mostrado cómo
se ven realmente las proteínas se ven
como grandes racimos son muy complejas
diferentes partes de las proteínas se
pueden enlazar a diferentes elementos y
cuando elementos enlazan a proteínas
cambia su forma pero estoy haciendo un
diagrama muy sencillo aquí y lo que
quiero mostrarte es que esta es nuestra
bomba sodio potasio en su estado
inactivo y lo que sucede en este caso es
que tenemos estos lindos lugares donde
nuestro sodio se puede enlazar en este
caso el sodio se puede enlazar a estos
puntos en nuestra enzima o proteína y si
se enlaza el sodio pero no metemos
energía al sistema nada sucederá solo
nos quedaremos en esta situación ahora
la proteína real se vería un poco
extraña la proteína podría ser ésta
la nube de proteína y luego los iones de
sodio quizás los iones de sodio se
enlacen allí ahí y ahí quizá estén
dentro de la proteína de alguna manera
pero aún no sucederá nada sólo con el
sodio enlazándose en este lado de la
proteína para que esto haga algo para
que pueda bombear algo al exterior
utiliza la energía de la atp tenemos
todos esos vídeos de la respiración y te
dije que el atp era la divisa de energía
en la célula bueno esto es algo útil que
hace el atp
en la atp el trifosfato de adenosina
podría ir a alguna otra parte de nuestra
encima pero en este diagrama quizá se va
esta parte de la enzima quizá este sea
el atp y esta enzima es un tipo de atp
cuando digo atp asa es porque rompe un
fosfato del atp y es solo por virtud de
su forma es capaz de romperlo cuando
separa el fosfato cambia su forma déjame
escribir los pasos de esto para que lo
recuerdes en el paso 1 tenemos a los
iones de sodio y de hecho déjame
contarlos tenemos 3 estas son las
proporciones reales tenemos 3 iones de
sodio
de él
dior
de la neurona
la sal
hola
vonn
qué es realmente una proteína que cruza
nuestra membrana ahora en el paso 2
tenemos también atp el atp
rompe en ha de ver más fosfato en la
proteína y eso cambia su forma para
proveer también
leer
energía
cam
guiar
la forma
cambiar la forma
hola
pon
esto representa cómo era nuestra bomba
antes y después podría verse algo así
déjame hacer algo de espacio aquí
dibujaré el cambio de la bomba ay eso es
antes y después de que el fosfato se ha
separado de la atp se verá algo así en
lugar de tener esa configuración se
abrirá en la otra dirección ahora podría
verse algo
y por supuesto está cargando estos iones
de sodio
tienen carga positiva está cargando esos
iones de sodio y se abre de esta manera
este lado ahora se ve de esta manera
ahora a los iones de sodio son liberados
al exterior han sido bombeados al
exterior y recuerda que esto necesita
energía porque va en sentido contrario
del gradiente natural estás tomando una
carga positiva y la estás empujando a un
ambiente que es incluso más positivo y
también la está llamando a un ambiente
donde ya hay mucho sodio y estás
poniendo más sodio ahí vas al contrario
del gradiente de carga y vas en contra
del gradiente de sodio pero ahora creo
que lo llamamos paso 3 el sodio es
liberado al exterior de las
y cuando esto cambia su forma ya no son
tan buenos los enlaces con el sodio por
lo que estos podrían volverse un poco
diferentes también por lo que el sodio
no puede ni siquiera enlazarse en esta
configuración ahora que la proteína ha
cambiado de forma debido a la atp así
que el paso tres los
n
más iones de sodio son liberados al
exterior
y
a tus
ex
dios
cuando ya estamos en esta configuración
tenemos a todos estos iones positivos
aquí afuera estos iones positivos
quieren estar lo más alejados posibles
los unos de los otros podrían incluso
atraerse a la célula misma porque la
célula es menos positiva en el interior
así que estos iones positivos y en
particular el potasio puede unirse a
este lado de la proteína cuando está en
esta que podemos llamar configuración
activa ahora creo que podemos llamarlo
paso 4
tenemos dos iones de potasio
en la salud
la que podemos llamar tumba
activa
bomba activa o bomba cambiada o quizá
podemos decir que está en su forma
abierta vienen aquí y cuando van ahí
vuelven a cambiar la forma de esta
proteína de regreso a esta forma a esta
forma abierta ahora cuando vuelve a la
forma abierta estos amigos ya no están
más aquí pero tenemos a estos dos amigos
aquí y en esta forma de aquí de repente
estos espacios
estos elementos de esta gran nube de
proteína no son buenos en quedarse
enlazados a estos iones de potasio por
lo que estos iones de potasio son
liberados en el interior de la célula
paso 5 esto cambia la forma de la bomba
por lo que la bomba cambia
más
original
y ya que estamos en la original estos
dos iones de potasio son liberados
adentro
lula
y tenemos en los siguientes vídeos
porque es útil tener a esos iones en el
interior podrías decir por qué no
seguimos bombeando cosas al exterior y
tendremos una diferencia de potencial
pero verás que estos iones de sodio
también son muy útiles cuál es el efecto
neto que está sucediendo acabamos con
más
iones de sodio en el exterior y acabamos
con más iones de potasio en el interior
pero mencioné que el interior es menos
positivo que el exterior estos dos son
ambos positivos no me importa si tengo
más potasio que sodio si pusiste
atención a las proporciones que mencioné
cada vez que utilizamos un atp bombeamos
al exterior tres odios y solo estamos
bombeando al interior 2 potasio cierto
bombeamos 3 odios y 2 potasio
cada uno tiene una carga positiva pero
cada vez que hacemos eso estamos sumando
una carga neta de 1 al exterior 3 al
exterior 2 al interior tenemos una carga
neta de 1
tenemos un +1 en el exterior
estamos haciendo al exterior más
positivo especialmente de manera
relativa al interior y esto es lo que
crea esta diferencia de potencial y si
de hecho tomas un voltímetro un
voltímetro mide diferencia de potencial
eléctrico y si tomas la diferencia de
voltaje entre este punto y este punto si
restar es el voltaje de aquí menos el
voltaje de allá obtendrás menos 70 mil
volts el cual es considerado como la
diferencia de potencial en reposo la
diferencia de potencial a través de la
membrana de una neurona cuando está en
su estado de reposo en este vídeo expuse
las bases de por qué y como una célula
que usa atp usando energía puede
mantener la diferencia de potencial a
través de su membrana donde el exterior
es ligeramente más positivo que el
interior de hecho tenemos una diferencia
de potencial negativa si comparamos el
interior con el exterior una carga
positiva querrá entrar si pudiera
hacerlo y una carga negativa quisiera
moverse
exterior si pudiera hacerlo ahora
podrías tener una última pregunta
podrías decir si esto sigue pasando si
solo seguimos sumando carga aquí nuestra
diferencia de potencial se volverá muy
negativa este sería mucho más negativo
que el exterior cómo se estabiliza en
menos 70 y para responder esa pregunta y
esto vendrá con muchos más detalles en
vídeos futuros también tienes canales
que realmente son estructuras proteicas
que en su posición abierta permitirán al
sodio atravesar los y también hay
canales que en su posición abierta
permitirán al potasio atravesar los en
su posición cerrada y hablaremos en el
siguiente vídeo de lo que sucede cuando
se abren pero en su posición cerrada aún
están un poco
me lees aún están permeables y digamos
que la concentración de potasio se
vuelve demasiado alta aquí y demasiado
alta significa cuando empiezan a
alcanzar este umbral de menos 70 mil
volts o mejor aún cuando la
concentración de sodio es muy alta hay
algunos de ellos que empezarán a gotear
y la concentración ahí se vuelve muy
alta esto es muy positivo y sólo por el
potencial eléctrico algunos de ellos
serán solo empujados a través nos
mantendremos alrededor de menos 70 mil
volts y si vamos más abajo quizá algo
del potasio atravesará al otro lado
incluso cuando estos dos están cerrados
si se vuelve demasiado ridículo si va a
menos 80 mil volts o menos 90 mil volts
de repente habrá un gran incentivo para
que muchos de estos iones se muevan a
través de sus respectivos canales
eso es lo que nos permite permanecer en
ese potencial estable en el siguiente
vídeo veremos qué pasa con este
potencial de voltaje cuando la neurona
está estimulada